i was like waiting like watching my
phone being like oh my god just like
anything while we all know now that the
cast of stranger things is nothing short
of full-blown stars the road to that
title could be considered a little crazy
so let's find out all the kooky stories
the cast experienced when auditioning
for the roles of a lifetime
number one primal fear indeed the actor
who completely inhabits the role of the
terrifying vechna actually had no idea
what role he was originally auditioning
for when they sent that through i was
like well i kind of know what this is
instead of being given a stranger things
script jaime was given sides to edward
norton's character in primal fear and an
excerpt of the movie hellraiser even
with all the mystery jamie still managed
to kill it literally it was all like
really instinctual i was like i'm just
gonna do it and just see what happens
number two to take joey originally
hailing from the uk joseph quinn never
worked in america before he was asked to
audition for the newest season of
stranger things in classic audition
style quinn sent in one self tape the
duffer brothers adored it so he sent in
a second and was offered the job the
turnaround was so quick that joseph
claims he doesn't know why the duffer
bros offered him the part of eddie
munson so readily
number three roller skating to success
when offered the role of max mayfield
sadie clearly was willing to do anything
to grab that role including telling a
lie well a half-truth it's true it was
not a lie i i haven't rolled away
when offered the part sadie very
confidently claimed she could roller
skate turns out the truth was she had
roller skated once in her life
regardless the role became hers and in
good actor fashion she very quickly
learned the skill
number 4. we get so emotional when
originally auditioning for the role of
11 the duffer brothers saw something in
millie but needed that extra oomph the
duffers just asked if we could have her
try it again when millie sent in a
second more emotional audition tape
everyone including casting director
carmen kuba was more than impressed and
the job was hers at that young age it
was very impressive as you can see on
the series fun fact millie spoke in her
american accent the entire audition
process even when speaking as herself to
the producers commitment is he
number five hauling in sick finn
immediately impressed the casting
director and producers by being so darn
funny in his audition tape which
happened to be filmed in his bed due to
him being sick
you could tell he had energy and was
really excited to play the part once he
booked the role finn continued his funny
streak by directing all the other kids
within the scenes he was in try to
imagine what it must have been like
when they cast the little rascals all
that bravado paid off because finn is
now about to direct his first feature
these kids are unstoppable remember two
days ago
with them had your trick number six
spielberg approved casting the part of
will byers was a challenge since the
character wasn't around much in the
first season but would be carrying the
second season so we were looking for a
lot from this character and he had had
experience on stage
once the casting director saw noah she
knew he had the innocence youth and
charm needed to tackle such a role and
since noah was coming off working with
steven spielberg a major duffer brothers
influence he was an immediate shoe-in
really just brought it every time we
called him in so it was very exciting to
see this first tape number seven eduardo
could have been an eddie newcomer
eduardo franco initially read for eddie
munson that role that has now made
joseph quinn a star however there are no
ill feelings towards losing the role to
joseph quinn in fact eddie has gone on
the record saying i'm so happy it went
to him he's so lovely they made a
beautiful decision i back it a hundred
percent
number eight hakuna matata means no
worries and great experience coming from
broadway as young simba caleb had the
power and energy needed to round out the
cast according to casting director
carmen kuba he nabbed the role instantly
and his energy created the chemistry
felt between the cast to this day can
you feel the love for caleb tonight
except i didn't tie it to a stream it
was actually flying
number 9. no bit player priya ferguson
who was originally supposed to have a
bit part in season 2 playing lucas's
iconic little sister erika was such a
powerhouse that the creative team
decided to include her in more scenes
she was eventually promoted for a bigger
recurring role in stranger things three
and continues her streak as erica in
season four thus proving there are no
small parts
number 10 right out of the gate sorry
gayton endeared himself to the creative
team and essentially booked the role of
dustin off his first audition he was an
excellent surprise he was such a
surprise performer that the duffer
brothers wanted to tailor the role to
gayton's real life personality talk
about flattering swear first
the most excellent problems you can make
number 11. hungry for the part
competition is tough for actors so
sometimes you need a real edge hi i'm
dicker and i'm going for the role of
billy
and actor daker montgomery understood
the assignment in one of the more famous
audition tales daker decided to make a
short film for his audition and finish
it off by mouthing hungry like a wolf in
a g-string
name's billy
number 12 a guess in the right direction
winona ryder was already a well-known
movie star but due to personal struggles
had been out of the spotlight for some
time that is until casting director
carmen kuba read the pilot of stranger
things upon reading the script carmen
felt a pull towards winona and took a
guess that she'd be perfect for the role
looks like this casting director could
go into the psychic business i think
that's like
it's in some way that is official
number 13. in this case it was literally
up to you new york new york casting
director carmen kuba had been a big fan
of david's for years and always held out
that he would someday be a star when the
stranger thing script crossed her desk
she knew that was the part for him and
in a tiny room in new york city david
harbor auditioned for stranger things
and carmen knew he got the part even in
the room
number 14 average joe the most average
of all the audition stories joe curie
originally auditioned for the part of
billy after a few months had passed the
duffer brothers couldn't get joe out of
their mind and asked him to audition for
the part of jonathan after that didn't
pan though the third time's a charm and
he nabbed the part of steve oh man the
jerky boyfriend okay whatever
and tbh joe always felt he wasn't suited
to jonathan and any steve fan can
thoroughly attest to that statement
number 15. talk isn't cheap fun fact the
part of robin may have gone to
bridgerton actress nicola cochlin
however maya hawk won the hearts of the
duffer brothers so much that they even
have modeled the way she speaks to fit
her character i'm talking like sibu
buffet on adderall or something like i
do this really
fast talking thing in the fourth season
robin has many a monologue which was
stressful for the actress but the
brothers assured hawke she'd memorize it
in two minutes since it's basically her
talking flattering
number 16. try and try again with her
first acting role in the hannah montana
movie at age 12 natalie was used to the
audition process however that doesn't
necessarily mean auditions were a piece
of cake for her when asked about her
process with the stranger things
audition natalie answered i auditioned
twice for the role i thought i bombed
the initial audition but then i got the
call back and i thought i bombed that as
well i guess in this instance bombing
actually means nailing it
you act like you don't even know us
number 17. in search of the loner
heartthrob when casting the part of
jonathan the duffer brothers felt it was
an uphill battle they wanted someone who
was mysterious edgy eccentric but not
too eccentric but also gentle a loner
and a heartthrob it was a very narrow
target after scouring the us the duffers
turned to the uk when they saw charlie
for the first time they relaxed they
found their jonathan and fans found
their heartthrob
number 18. didn't need to haunt anyone's
dreams for this part as an 80s horror
movie staple robert freddy krueger
england originally wowed the casting
director when he auditioned for crooked
mayor larry klein and while they passed
on him for that part a year later when
the part of spooky victor creel came up
he was just the man for the part
number 19. wine time cara buono has been
on the acting beat since she was 12. so
she knew a good script when she saw one
and according to bono she knew she
wanted to be in the show as soon as she
read the pilot of stranger things and
just a little look into her acting
process buono was the one who decided to
make mrs wheeler a wine drinker
number 20. mad about paul while this tv
veteran may have not been watching the
show his son got him on the bandwagon
real quick once paul was offered a part
he was thrilled to be on the
self-proclaimed the coolest show on tv i
didn't know for a long time which way
he's going so that was kind of cool and
it didn't take much for paul to say yes
since the duffer brothers didn't even
give him a script but a limited
description of the character not even
knowing if he was a good or bad guy word
of mouth matters well it was a wild ride
but the casting was dead on when it came
to creating the world that the duffer
brothers set out to do when putting
together the cast of stranger things
which casting story caught your eye
comment below and be sure to like and
subscribe to the things